- Are you a recovering addict?
- [Interviewer] No, I'm actually not.
- So you're ignoring me,
that's just enthused with
the lifestyle of-
- Yeah, I just find this.
- Fascinating, right?
- [Interviewer] Here's what it is,
I am fascinated by the human
tendency to self-destruct.
- Oh.
- [Interviewer] That can
take many different forms.
Down here you get the drug addiction,
the gang violence, the prostitution,
but it could also be gambling,
eating, shopping-
- Fucking,
there's all types.
- So many
different things.
- Yeah.
- There's laziness.
- Uh-huh.
- [Interviewer] Alright Latonya.
- Hello.
- [Interviewer] Where
are you from originally?
- I'm from St. Louis,
Missouri, I love my hometown.
I must say California,
and all these other places
are truly a joke to me
(laughing) they're a joke.
- [Interviewer] How was your childhood,
did you grow up with both your parents?
- No unfortunately, my dad was killed
while my mom was six
months pregnant with me.
And I'm the fourth child
from five, out of five,
so I love to tell this part of my story
where all of my brothers and sisters
had the same dad except for me,
and then it goes back to the same father,
which lets me know mom
stepped out of relationship,
so, hey.
Gettin' back to my dad's death,
he was killed by my aunt's husband,
who she is still today married with.
He was, he jumped in front of an ice pick,
this was in Chicago and the hospital
was really, really far away,
so he bled to death, he bled.
And so like most men in my life
he should've still been here.
(laughing)
However, you know my grandfather,
he had wheat and a cotton field.
There was 16 of my mother's, siblings,
all, again, 16 of 'em.
We had land in St. Louis,
which was a wheat and cotton field
and that was all taken by, you know,
the government started
taking people's land.
However, there is still
the three-story bedroom,
I mean, house, that still stands
which has family secrets inside.
And, my mom and,
I'm gonna say about six of her sisters,
were molested by their uncles
and I believe some of their brothers.
So that's when my oldest aunt made a way
for my mom to come out here.
And she only had one
daughter, and four boys,
and my oldest aunt thing was,
there's no way I'm gonna
allow my daughter to be,
you know, did, how we were did,
and it's okay for me to curse?
- [Interviewer] Yeah of course.
- Because I'm trying to watch my language.
- [Interviewer] No, you
can say anything you like.
- Yeah, so, I remember
my mom telling me that,
she told her like, "Mae,
you got four fucking girls
and there's no way I know you want them
to experience what we experienced."
"So I'll go first and then
I'll make a way for you
and then I'll send back
for the rest of 'em."
So my aunt did that, she
came down here, whatever,
and she slowly sent back for 'em,
so let me speed it up
a little bit, burrrrr.
So now I'm 10 years old and
I'm out here in California
and we start off on 59th and McKee Avenue,
I love that 'cause
that's where my cousins,
started Five Nine East Coast Crib,
which is big man, rest in peace,
and my cousin Clifton, who
is doing life in San Quentin.
So, (hands clapping) now let's get to me.
I felt myself kind of
fucked up at 10 years old
for the simple fact I
remember seeing things,
I remember seeing things
that I knew was not right.
I remember feeling things
that I knew was not right,
and that was wrong, but
it used to freak me out
because it felt good that it was wrong.
So I guess I was a twisted
little kid already at 10.
So, I was fascinated
with women with boobs,
coming up 10 years old.
This is where my life,
this is where I remember
my life, at 10 years old.
I remember liking women with boobs,
women that were natural,
women that had ass.
You know, a man, just really,
really wasn't my thing,
anything that I got from a
man, it was more so how to sit,
how to do this, how to
talk, how to smack a bitch,
you know, things like that.
So, that was really the
way I looked up to men and,
till I realized they had
something that I didn't have,
which was a dick and that there was no way
that a woman was truly gonna want me,
because I didn't have the
one thing that, men did have.
So we're gonna speed it up.
So then that made me very, very angry
'cause there was some
chick I was really digging
in grammar school.
I mean, she was flawless.
Her name was Sabrina Marino.
She had little black freckles,
and long black jack curly hair,
and she had a smile that
was out of this world.
And whenever I would see
her it would take me back
to the fucking movies
like when somebody is
walking in slow motion,
and her fucking hair is blowing,
and her dress is raising up and shit,
and my heart would
literally really, really,
really beat, so there's a true factor,
that's not fake.
So, anyway, I would tell myself
I'm gonna marry this woman.
In fact, I started getting in trouble
with creative writing and shit
because you supposed
to write what you wanna
do when you grow up,
or who you wanna marry,
what celebrity crushes,
there, and mine was all women,
so of course the teacher reads that shit,
she finds it disturbing.
Her name was Ms. Bordenabor,
I developed a crush on her
she was a fucking real
kick ass, nice sexy legs,
wore them spike high heels,
wore them fishnet stockings,
and she was a little,
I call 'em bite size,
anything you can pick up and
put on a counter, or a shelf,
I call them bite size.
And she had a short hair cut
and she had a little fine mustache
and she would always
wear that red lipstick
that would just make you say,
"Fuck that mustache, this bitch is bad."
So of course, even in that
grade, we had creative writing
and her thing was who
is your biggest crush
and I wrote her and what
I wanted to do to her.
So immediately I was taken out of class
and I was suspended for undressing
the teacher with my eyes.
(laughing)
That made me feel some type of way
because anytime I got suspended,
I got my fucking ass beat.
So, I guess that's what
you call resentments,
I'm still holding on to that shit.
I believe that's something else
that keeps me gettin' loaded.
And I have to take a
deep breath on this one,
'cause even today I still have
issues dealing with it, so.
Let's go to when I was about 13,
when the molestation started.
where I realized my mom was codependent,
and she just had to have
a man to validate her.
Beautiful woman, strong woman, but again,
that codependent issue.
And I just realized that
it was truly a problem
when I completed Life Skills.
Codependency is some real
shit and it's a real issue
that some people just
don't realize they have.
So anyway, let's get to where,
there was again, there was four girls
and one boy in my family.
And mind you, we came all
the way from St. Louis
to keep this shit from happening,
yet we get out here in California
and my mom run through these men like,
like you run through a bag of Skittles,
not too fast, not too slow.
But, I remember the first man
and his name was Robert
Maxy, rest in peace.
Now she would get some real nice,
this motherfucker had green
eyes, he was yellow bone,
had good hair, you know,
but again, I'd just like to,
I just wanted, you know,
the manliness about 'em,
so I looked at him as like a father figure
'cause here it is, like I
told you at 10 years old,
I was fucked up, you know already
with feeling this way about women.
So, I liked the fact that
he had the green eyes,
and the curly hair,
so I told like my mom, "Like
I'll cut all this shit off,
I don't want this no more,
I want a little ass curl
like Robert, right?"
And she was like, "No, no,
no, you can't do that."
So anyhow, Robert turns
out to be a real asshole.
His thing was, he wanted
to fuck all of us,
he wanted to keep it in
the family, as they say.
And, I remember that fucker
getting my mom pissy drunk
and putting her down to sleep
and we, my mom always kept the house,
so we had a house where
there was one bedroom
in the beginning, and
that was my mom's bedroom,
and then I remember him
late night creeping,
my oldest sister has really huge breasts,
they're really, really huge, right,
so she couldn't sleep with
a shirt on, or a gown,
but those fuckers at 15,
were like out to here dude, you know,
and now they're out to here
now that she's a grown woman.
Mine are trying to slowly catch up.
But, I remember him, seeing him going,
opening up the door,
pulling the sheet off of her
and she just raises up
and there's her breasts
and she's fighting,
trying to get the cover.
And then I would go and step in
and you know I would be like,
"Hey, you're not supposed to be in here."
And he would say, he
would turn around and say,
"You know you're next you little bitch,
your mother will never believe you,"
and that's where codependency comes in at,
she was blind, she was blinded.
So anyway,
I remember the next day
I was telling my mom,
no me going and telling my mom, saying,
"You gotta keep Robert
out of Bridget's room,
that's gonna mess with her mentally."
And I remember my mom's telling
me, looking at me saying,
"What the fuck are you talking about?"
"You know, you talk too fucking much."
And now that I know what
I know about codependency
it's like, damn mom,
did you like sell Bridgette to Robert?
I mean, what the fuck was this about,
to where I'm coming to you telling you
and it's like I talk too much,
what am I talking about?
But anyhow, you would never
know my mom was in an addiction.
And, don't get me wrong,
I love my mom to death.
The only thing I would
change about my mom,
is that codependency, but
she's resting in peace,
she died 25 years clean, so hey,
she's still my protege,
she's still my number one,
she's still my best friend.
But she had some fucking issues
that really, really really just,
fucked all of her daughters up.
Well my mom, from the
day my mom said that,
I just figured like this,
if a nigger gonna touch
me I'm gonna get paid,
so the game, the chase was off.
So, next boyfriend she had,
my sister was doing her own thing
so now it was all about me.
I was the only adult figure in the house.
So,
he would come in, and we had bunk beds,
he would come in when,
I was at the lower bunk,
and he would come in
and he would wake me up
and he would put his hand over my mouth,
talking about a different one now.
He put his hand over my
mouth and he would be like,
"Hey, I've got $10 for
you for school tomorrow,
you know your mom only
gives you guys three,
and you're a growing up girl."
Can you still hear me?
"And you're a growing up girl,
so I want you to take
10 bucks," he's like,
and I looked up at him and I said,
"Motherfucker make it 20,"
and that's when it was on.
So every boyfriend she had
I began to look for his fucked up ways
so that I could take 'em down, right?
There was never no sex involved.
There was one that,
this motherfucker (laughing),
(fist smacking hand)
straight true crack head.
He is the motherfucker
that let me know that
he'll sell his mama, okay,
because I wouldn't even,
we weren't even his kids,
but I remember him telling
all his friends like,
yeah these are my daughters,
these are my beautiful
girls, woot-ta-woo-woo.
When all along he was hint, hinting, yeah,
(laughing) I got these products, right?
We were fucking products, merchandise.
So I started getting addicted to money.
So then I would tell him like,
"You got any friends,
you got any friends I could,"
My breasts was the hottest
thing going on when I was young,
right, because niggers
wasn't trying to really,
unless they was crazy, wasn't
trying to lay down with you,
but they didn't mind fondling there,
that's where I got my
sugar daddies and all that.
So, I mean, hustling
became, at 14 hustling,
I had sugar daddies,
I had a little, married a
little (indistinct) man.
Yeah my breasts, my breasts
was the hottest thing going
and to feel the motherfuckers was 30,
to suck on 'em was 50.
I mean, hey, my breasts, again,
I wish they would've had YouTube back then
'cause I show 'em when I
had my own little website.
So then we wanna speed it
up to when I'm about 14, 15,
she gets with this Mexican
that I had already,
I had already let grope
me, and everything,
for 60 bucks on the side of the building.
He was living in a trailer
and I had already let him grope me,
so I'm gonna say, that's when
my addictive personality came,
when I was about 13 or 14.
So, she decides,
she's gonna marry him, right,
and help him get papers.
So this is where my nightmare begins.
So now I done groped you on the side,
but you ain't got the decency,
now that you're with my mom, to let it go.
So now you wanna start blackmailing me
and my mom was just like zero tolerance
of us doing any type of
fucking, dating, doing anything.
So,
the bastard raped me.
I had let my, my mom was working,
my brother joined a gang, so
it left me and my baby sister
and once I got home, I was,
start prepping shit for dinner,
and make that sorry
motherfucker lunch, or whatever,
and you know, do what my mom's duties was.
And I remember when going
to take a shower, or a bath,
and I had a robe on and I remember,
right when I was getting
ready to take the robe off
that fucker came in and pinned me down
and with his little
wrinkled fucked up dick,
even though it didn't last
a minute, here it is today.
I got a 24-year-old El
Salvadorian daughter,
she's beautiful, looks just like me.
Still trying to get
connected with her, but,
yeah, that's a nightmare there.
So anyway, I wound up
having a daughter behind,
my first born,
and that's when I became very, very angry.
I couldn't stand men,
and I didn't want this shit
to happen to my baby sister so,
I told the neighbors and,
when it was time for
me to deliver the baby
the doctor saw that there
was wounds down there
and that he just pressured
me, and pressured me,
and asked me was it a
consensual pregnancy,
like, did I want this?
It's amazing what, and
this was right before
technology was coming up,
it's amazing how a scar could say,
what type of scar, what
type of way it began,
can tell a lot.
So anyway this doctor knew that I had been
forcefully taken, and that's
how the pregnancy came about.
And, I finally went to
my mom and I was like,
I told her like okay, like,
'cause she kept saying
that I was pregnant,
she kept accusing me
of fucking around with,
in the streets and my mind
wasn't even there, you know,
and that's where I've
developed this model of,
if you're gonna keep on accusing me
then I'm gonna give you
what you accusing me of doing anyway.
So,
I just became real promiscuous you know.
I just, but it have to be
about money, so I guess,
I don't know, I guess I became
somewhat addicted to that lifestyle.
So then I'm gonna speed it up to,
I got addicted to money.
And then all of my home
girls they were selling dope.
So here it is, I got,
my daughter,
and I'm trying to make it,
I wanted what my home girls
had which was selling dope
so I got into the dope game.
I started my own spot over
on Stafford and Imperial
and I used to do a score
for the Nickerson Gardens,
and I almost got killed,
I almost lost my life trying to open up
my own dope spot,
in somebody else's neighborhood and shit.
But I went hard in the paint
and that's when I learned
anything that I do,
I gotta do it wholeheartedly,
or not at all.
If I'm not winning,
and if I don't like it,
or if I've got no calls to doing it,
then I don't fuck with it.
You know, I'm not saying I'm a saint,
but I'm also a little daredevil
and I love to challenge a man
because I'm already angry
with the motherfuckers
'cause I don't got a dick.
That's the one thing
that a nigger got on me
that I ain't got, and I'll tell you,
I just, I despise men 'cause
they got a penis and I don't.
But I can pull a broad on me,
I can talk a broad up outta her panties.
So, here it is I almost
got killed selling dope
over somebody else's
neighborhood and shit.
And then, so I had the little
gangsta takeover where,
okay bitch, you wanna
sell dope in our hood,
we got shifts up in here.
So I had a little bit of everybody
up in there selling dope.
And I remember it being
shootouts, all type of shit.
So anyway, I just winded
up abandoning the place,
I just left it.
I left the place to
get with my baby daddy,
which is Evil Deed from Bounty Hunters,
and I got with him, and
he was a primo head.
And then I started,
he started taking my money and shit,
and then I started
selling dope on the side
without him knowing, out of a little spot,
out of a little room on 108th and Grape.
And I'm selling dope
out of that little room
and then they ran the T-zones,
and the groceries, ran up in there,
to rob him thinking that
he was selling the dope,
but I was the one selling the dope.
So once he found out I was selling dope,
it started getting real hectic,
it started getting real hectic.
He started beatin' the shit out of me,
it just got real crazy, and um, yeah.
So then, he put me on a track,
so now I'm out here prostituting,
I'm out here for real, for real,
with almost like a real live pimp.
So, I'm out here on Fig and 87th,
like if I got a motherfucking shift,
and one thing I just couldn't do,
I refused to put on
the fucking high heels,
and the little fucking
dress, and all that shit,
I refused to do that.
So, young girls were selling.
So I went with the look of a teenager
and boy did it sell.
I had some motherfuckers.
I had a regular that he would get a motel,
and he would wanna do
the scenery type shit
that I was his daughter
and he was my daddy
and he would be coming down the stairs,
and I mean, this motherfucking
motel had a refrigerator,
this motherfucker would
stop, buy milk and cookies,
put all that shit in the
refrigerator, set it up,
and then he would buy me
this little da-da thing,
so that I when I bend over,
I will bend over just right
to where as he's coming down the stairs,
and then I'm supposed to,
I had a script that I was
supposed to like say, like,
"Oh yeah daddy, ooh man, I'm sorry".
And he would be like, "Oh, it's okay,
you're daddy's little girl."
And he would, I was really small man,
so he would pick me up,
set me on a counter,
and he would stand in front of me,
he would say, I would say,
"Oh daddy I ate up all the cookies."
And he would be like,
"It's okay, daddy wants
something else to eat."
And he would begin to go down on me.
And I'm telling you, I would have to be
fucking loaded out of my
mind to go through with that,
because I have daughters, you know.
I mean I've done some demoralizing shit
out here to where I couldn't
even sleep at night.
So that's when I picked up drugs.
I needed to numb, you know,
to suppress going out here
and with these sick individuals.
I winded up a Skid Row
in my first drug program
and I got kicked out of there
and that's when I winded up
on Skid Row, smoking dope,
deeply selling myself and,
jacking people, all that shit came along
with Skid Row.
Shaking motherfuckers pockets up and down,
having unprotected sex with motherfuckers
that you could really look at 'em
and like possibly tell that they had some.
In fact, I'm gonna go ahead
and open up and share this,
and I'm still waiting for
the results to come back.
I just, right when my husband died,
I turned my first trick again
and it was with somebody
that had full-blown AIDS,
and I knew they had full-blown AIDS
but I had the fuck-its.
My husband was gone and,
I can't commit suicide,
it's not an option.
I knew this person had full-blown AIDS,
but I want a way out so bad that,
I mean, this life to me
ain't worth really living no more.
I mean, my husband was my everything and,
without him, I feel
I just feel like
all these motherfuckers
out here that just,
my husband was a good solid man.
And all these nothing-ass motherfuckers,
I mean, it's many a nights
that I lay out here now,
that I am on the street again,
due to my husband's death.
I'm back smoking again,
harder than I ever before,
in fact, I tried to suck my first dick
two weeks ago without a condom.
I mean, they say the runs get,
it gets progressively
worse and all that shit,
all the do's and the gets and shit,
I knew this person had full-blown AIDS,
but to make that $100
I went ahead and did it
and every other day I'm
going to get tested.
I got my two dogs now,
which is Shadow and Teddy,
and they're the only thing
that keeps me going right now,
that keeps me from snapping.
I look at all the foul shit
that people do all here
and I feel like they
don't deserve to live.
Here it is my husband, a good honest man,
from the most vicious
notorious gang that there is,
Latin Kings, they called
him, Blacky, rest in peace.
Here it is, this man
changed for the better,
not for the worst, and here
it is his life was taken.
He should still be here.
And without him,
I feel, I feel nothing.
- [Interviewer] Where are you living now?
- Right now I'm living on Skid Row.
- [Interviewer] You in a tent?
- No, I don't do the tents,
anything I do I want
you to see me doing it
and I try to do it in a respectful way,
but there ain't no closed doors out here,
fuck a tent, (chuckling).
Anybody could plant a bug in your tent.
- [Interviewer] And how are
you supporting yourself?
- I'm back to prostituting.
Yeah, I mean, it's hard ball again.
I'm smoking dope, I'm
prostituting again on the low,
'cause I got the dogs,
if I find a dog sitter,
and I got a two-bedroom voucher,
but because of COVID it gets
really hard to find a place.
So at this point I don't
know where my life is gonna,
what turn it's gonna make?
Will I make it out of here?
I mean, I don't know.
Do I wanna make it outta here?
Yeah, but then no,
truthfully speaking, yes and no.
And that's because I don't got my husband,
that was my everything.
But the way I see it
now, on a spiritual tip,
God has broken me down for that,
so that I could rebuild again
and what I gathered, I ended up this.
He wants me to want nobody, but him,
he's a jealous God.
He wants me to depend on nobody but him.
He wants me to need nobody but him.
Hell, he knows when I'm
gonna get my next hit.
He knows where it's coming from
and who's gonna give it to me.
So,
that's just, basically
that's just about it
and this is where I am today
right here in the heart
of Skid Row, once again.